there's a lot of smart people that come
up to me and they say Pat this business
thing is a piece of cake I have a job
I'm an executive I have a degree from
XYZ and I'm thinking about being a
business owner and it's going to be so
easy for me and they go in extremely
arrogant and cocky and then they fail
and they wonder why okay so in this
video today I'm gonna cover with you why
smart people so often fail in business
and I'll unpack it for you on twelve
different points or so I think I have
used to cover with you but I want to
tell you story that really impressed me
so much
Arnold Schwarzenegger is done being a
governor okay he's done it's mr. Olympia
seven times you know he's gone out there
and become an actor in all these
different movies and he's Merida Kennedy
and he becomes the governor two terms
California liberal state he's a
Republican he's done the impossible and
multiple different areas of his life
watch what happens after he's done being
a governor after the scandal with his
wife which if you haven't read the book
Total Recall I highly recommended let's
put a picture here a pill to recall they
asked him to here what do you want to do
says I want to go back into Hollywood
said oh wow are you like excited about
playing a type roles and all this other
stuff he says no I have to make sure
that I earn everyone's respect that I
still know how to act I have to start
off as a beginner again and I have to
take any job they give me now think
about this here is a man with a resume
bigger than the Bible as far as a resume
goes he can put so many different things
in there and he says I have to earn
everyone's respect I think that's one of
the reasons why he's constantly won in
his life and I think that's one of the
reasons why smart people have a very
hard time with business so step number
one first I'm going to talk about I
chose twelve different points and I put
one about number one because that I
don't believe anything is above this I
don't believe anything is above this for
smartly so if you're watching this and
you know who you are and you're smart
you think you're smart you consider
yourself smart or maybe very smart and
you think you're smarter than everybody
else you meet it out there in the room
rule number one will bite you in the
butt
let me tell you ocean disappears what
social ocean is a mentality that's
called the beginner's mind
that once the beginners mindset goes I
don't care how big you are I don't care
how wealthy you are I don't care how
powerful you are I don't care how much
influence you have I don't care how many
Instagram YouTube Facebook Twitter how
many followers you have when the
beginner's mind goes away and you're no
longer learning and improving and
figuring out ways to make yourself
better you are toast let me tell you why
here's why just ten years ago in and has
only been on for 20 years or so not two
it's been out longer but just 20 years
that became publicized and while using
it then came a AOL chat and then all of
a sudden came net zero some of you guys
remember in that zero then came you know
on myspace which was very big you put
your song then came you know Friendster
was before them might say then Facebook
then Instagram then now then Twitter you
know insta - it came before then Twitter
you know and then now snapchat now
there's there's all this stuff going on
business is changing and it's changing
so rapidly so rapidly that it requires
you and I to learn rapidly so if you're
not a new CEO or new entrepreneurs new
business on a new executive every single
day with that mentality of men I know
nothing and I'm going to keep learning
you're going to be in trouble if
Socrates on his deathbed said the only
thing I know is nothing and here's one
of the most famous you know philosophers
of all time what makes you and I think
we know all this stuff we don't so the
mentality why smart people fail is
because they already know enough second
thing too conservative sometimes
a smart person comes in and they've
already been taught of certain ways or
their minds already been built up in a
certain way they are way way too
conservative way way too safe and in the
world of business sometimes it gets ugly
you know sometimes it gets dirty
sometimes there's some risks you got to
take you just got to take and it's not
conventional risk it's not conventional
thing that I'm supposed to be doing this
no you can't lean oh there's some times
that you got to do some stuff that you
can't read in any book or any video some
value tainment
literally there are certain things in
business that's like what do I do in a
situation like this I'm working on a
book right now I'm flying over to New
York to talk to a handful of major
publishers because they want me to
book that has to do with specifically on
how to process issues once we learn how
to process issues but still if you're
too conservative you're going to be
toast in the world of business there's
going to be times in business that you
have to do certain things that no one's
going to think about but smart people
typically just go to to abide the rules
what they follow not logs not laws not
regulations rule it's a different story
they're afraid of breaking rules
sometimes conservative even our next
over-promised under-deliver is they're
so smart they know so much that they
coming across as you know we're going to
be able to do this and I'm going to be
able to do this and they give so many
different promises to everybody and they
don't deliver so many different promises
and they don't deliver and eventually
people say I don't want to do business
with this person if you are going to
make promises you better deliver I will
never forget we're about to start a
company called PHP this is October 1 I'm
I'm having lunch with a man named Bill
in San Bernardino Valley and I am
obsessed with capitalism how much I went
to a meeting in Miramar Hotel Santa
Monica I am obsessed with capitalism I
am so obsessed with temples and
entrepreneurship like to the point where
I believe capitalism everything in my
blood is about entrepreneurship
immigrants from Iran 1.8 GPA divorced
family not the smartest cat on the block
no one in school thought I was going to
go on a ride and play sports I'm just a
guy that worked at haagen-dazs and I
worked at Burger King and Bob's Big Boy
there's nothing on my resume says this
guy's going to go places
so all of a sudden I start level
capitalism because it gave me an
opportunity as long as I can work hard
and improve I can compete with anybody
I mean it's diner in San Bernardino
Valley right off the 210 freeway to the
north side of it and I'm having this
meeting that were all the way in the
back I said listen this is what I want
to propose I think I think an immigrant
and a group of immigrants like myself we
can come together and we can bring the
spirit of free enterprising capitalism
and entrepreneurship to America in the
world and this man bill turns around and
says the following thing to my face it
says Patrick don't you say it unless if
you deliver if you're going to say it
you better deliver because no one's
going to believe you so you said think
twice before
making this massive of a crusade a
launch to the public because if you
don't deliver you become a hypocrite
you'll become somebody who constantly
over promises and under delivers and you
become another person that uses just
their intelligence not someone who comes
through I thought about it I came back
and we said we're doing it and he said
okay so the pressures now on you and we
have to deliver right so you got to make
sure if you do this you best deliver
smart people sometimes they're so
logical that they have a hard time
delivering with this because everything
is so logical for them next fact driven
it's a perfect transition with this so
look there is a there is a part with
raising kids where I got three kids and
my two boys they're in the MMA phase
right now there's a five and three year
old these kids want to fight all the
time like I don't need to go to
pay-per-view and ask Dana wife what next
fights going to be between Conor
McGregor and you know Nick Diaz I just
need to sit down watch these two boys go
at it and literally the other day Paul
and I were in LA okay I'm in LA pause
the babysitter for half a second I made
the mistake of making Paul the
babysitter for split second Paul's in
the back and Paul is doing something
with the camera Tico and Dylan they're
sitting in their seat I'm driving all of
a sudden you hear my son screaming ahh
all the substance of the younger son
we're not bullying all the time and I
got to talk to younger son up and my
older son is bleeding everywhere here
right and so this kid hit some scratches
on all this stuff and now I have to sit
there and when you have kids you know
it's like all I'm going to raise kids
and factually you're supposed to love
them and you don't do this and you just
have so many facts you know logically
we're suppose marriage raising kids it's
so amazingly emotional that if you don't
get away if you get away from the
emotional heart beat side of both of
their feelings and the way you
communicate with them you're going to
lose them right now have a daughter
and my daughter is going to be
completely different than my two sons
that I have what's the point I'm making
you business has a heartbeat and in
business if you only treat it logically
it's going to die it needs emotions it
needs to be fired up in
needs to be driven you can't just take
everything logically and go out there
and drive everything logically there's
certain times that you can't just go out
and use facts there are certain times
that you got to use examples of
something that happened that story based
there are certain times you may be
sitting in a room and you're looking at
the numbers and all the numbers suck you
are getting killed I have been in
meetings where our company we were
getting hammered
I lost the number one producer had to
fire an offer to Utah and all this stuff
that we have to do I'm in front of the
guy's wife our numbers are like this for
six months straight and in a factual
meaning I'm supposed to sit there and
say what well guys we suck we suck we
are going out of business no no no in
that moment in that moment you need to
know emotion heart why do we start this
why are we doing this what's the purpose
it is how do they all just get started
why would why were we doing this
business here tell me show me some
emotion where's your heart at what are
you thinking about this is what we this
is are we going to get tougher how are
we going to respond here in that moment
I learn a lot about the heartbeat of our
leaders let me tell what happened the
smartest person in the room quit the
person with the fanciest degrees in the
room quit the person with the fancy
resume in the room quit logical complete
logical then the other person are
sitting there saying you know what
you're right and all the other guys that
were in the room now own the company why
logic versus emotion it's just how
things work out sometimes makes me
mentality this is a tough one because
the challenge and part about smart
people is it's so much about me I got to
build my resume we get people that come
and go a lot of people that want to work
with me just to say have work with
pampers they live it on value to me they
want to add it to their resume they kind
of go they come and go they kind of go
me me me me I got to build my resume I
got to build my resume I got to build my
resume I got to build my revenue to my
build my resume build my resume build my
resume there comes a time where this
entire thing called life you realize
it's really not about you and I and let
me actually what I mean by that like if
you want to build an empire that's very
very big if it's only about you
eventually people will realize it and
you don't inspire anybody because it's
all about a mean mentality
it's got to be run the people around you
what are their dreams one of my favorite
conversations to have with any one of
our employees any one of our salespeople
anybody I do business with it'll be a
regular conversation at a lunch or
coffee or something this is what our
what's your vision of life what do you
want to do how do you see yourself what
type of a role you want to see yourself
being here on the team where you act oh
oh and people don't know what do you
what do you want to do and I love sit
down I was asked this question so many
times I have subscription people start
shaking around me like why are you
nervous because I don't have to have you
what let's find out this thing called
life goes like this might at 74 years
old he was hospitalized for two and a
half week like this then called life
goes like like fix it goes I just had my
friends I was in LA visiting her uncle
died another uncle died all of a sudden
these are people I had dinner with like
this so what's your purpose it does tell
me I want to have a role here I want to
do this and I want to be part of this I
want to one day like I have two
employees both girls both girls look at
this both of them tell me one day I want
to be the CEO the company and there's
there's some other people that aren't
there one day I want to be the president
one day I want to do this girls are
telling me they want to be the CEO the
company most awesome guess what I want I
want people that say things like that
and I want to make sure that they mean
it because there's a difference between
you know saying it and not meaning it
they say and they mean it well if you
want to be a CEO one you got to do that
that that's that you got to read these
books you got to work like that you got
to get these I want to do that one the
Great King versus kingmaker it can't be
all about you and smart people it's
about them because when you go to school
what the school teach you you got to
build your resume sometimes and
sometimes it's a beneficial thing to
work for big for because you build your
resume and you want it's just so much
about this crap that these educators
university professors are teaching
people and they're developing people
like this that become me mentality
maybe it is
designed to create people like that
right levena kingmaker business is all
about being a kingmaker how can you take
somebody who's a nobody in the company
yet and then develop them to be somebody
that they have a responsibility amongst
other people that's the kingmaker you're
developing people after finding out
exactly what they want next entitlement
entitlement is I worked with a lady in
the past and I told myself I will never
do this intentionally I said I will
never do this never do this and this
lady extremely talented she thought she
was smarter than everybody else she
thought she was smarter than everybody
else and so what happened one time is I
saw a trend that's what the trend was we
all would come up with great ideas and
she would always take the credit for the
ideas and one time it became public and
other people came up and said what Pat
we came up with this idea why shall we
taking credit for this idea and I would
100% at a time
I always protected this lady it's just
my nature 100% of time always protected
this lady says we're doing business
together but then she started taking it
to a whole different level a whole
different level whole different level
you know the first thing I said to
myself that by the way she did a lot of
things right she's a lot of things up
but this one thing here's what it did
all it made me think about is and the
ideas she took so much credit because
it's all about her I don't ever want to
do this ever so here at the hospice we
have very simple point system we kid
about and we have joke about a lot
whoever that comes with the idea we're
supposed to say who came with the idea
and we give credit to the person that
gave birth to the idea why what because
it is what it is the other day yeah Lois
is a newer guys who are team Colombian
guy play basketball right he's behind
the camera you'll see space one these
days he comes as a Patrick you know I
think we need to get this camera look at
this you know he's shown me that what
did you call that camera thing what's
the call wait let's go awesome all it's
awesome all my scene all right
and it balances right right then I said
Luis what can we do today how about we
get a virtual reality starts doing
research and sending us all this stuff
man that's not my idea I don't know this
he's coming up with this idea how to
make it stabilizer because we're doing a
blog and Paul and I going on or what if
we get some like cool
so we want to create that environment
because it can't be about you getting
the credit now here's a challenge with
smart people they love taking the credit
man but they hate taking a blame yeah
it's a tough one ain't it it's like man
just because I'm such a great leader in
this but hey you guys suck in this area
that's not my fault that's not the right
I've never thought I would never listen
if you want to make it in business
credit goes here blame goes here the
only way you build kings if credit goes
here and blame goes here you build kings
if credit goes to your blame goes here
you're the king
it's kingmaker there's a lot of guys
online that you know are YouTube
sensations and experts and all this
other stuff you know what I always want
to ask here's what I always want to ask
show me one or two people around you
that have been successful that work
closely with you and you don't hear any
aims it's just as their name this is why
our YouTube channel is not called
Patrick where David it's called value
taming because we're going to bring a
lot of talents on value tainment
we're going to recruit a lot of talents
on value tainment lots of your feet this
is just the beginning wait till we get
to a million subs there's a vision with
what we going to do with value tainment
lots of vision what we going to do with
vitamin but it ain't about the brand
it's about the people that represent the
brand so smart people have a hard time
with credit their title driven I'm this
position I'm that position I'm this
position you're too smart for business
business is about what what place can i
elevate here not what position can I
build you from our resume what position
can i elevate here what can I do here to
get them going right next one it's been
mistake once admit mistakes say I'm done
wrong I'm sorry I did this I'll fix it
here's once and I learned a long time
ago you know it's the fastest way to
finish a argument if you're at fault you
know it's the fastest way I'm sorry I'm
at fault let me tell you where I learned
my wife and I would get into heated
arguments like I'm talking heated
arguments that belong in movies right
heated arguments that end up turning
into three babies afterwards but really
really heated arguments that we have
right and so eventually I'm like you
know what
I'm tired I just there's no purpose for
this what the hell am i arguing for this
here if I'm at fault so here's what I
would say
babe babe do you realize what happened
you're right this was my fault this is
my fault and so I started 100% right off
the bat saying it's my fault and there's
not remember my ego I got an ego so
everyone has got an ego they got to deal
with baby it's my fault
whoa then she would say baby it's my
fault
then it became a culture in our
relationship babe this one's my fault eh
come on babe I know I just told you it's
my fault I'm sorry I know I'm just upset
okay cool
like cool it's my fault that's it no
one's killed no one's getting arrested
it's all right we make mistakes I don't
walk on water I don't want to walk on
what I don't want to be known for being
perfect and walking on water and need to
do you it's a lonely place to be you're
always walking on eggshells man when you
when you have to act like two being so
perfect
next lack of selling vision sometimes
it's so logical that they don't sell
vision you gotta sell vision where we're
going these two are kind of similar but
you always got to know where we going
where's this thing going next where's a
company going to next next there try to
outsmart hard work now there's a whole
debate going on right now where
everyone's posting questions enemies
snap hey Pat this guy on YouTube said
everything is about hard work but this
kind of YouTube said you know it's about
working smarter what do you think is the
smartest thing you know I'm like okay
what are you trying to say what do I
have to work harder I'd have to work
smart I can't say that I've met a single
person that became successful that
didn't have to work hard for period of
their lives
I don't know anybody I don't know
anybody that didn't work or like I
honestly I don't know one person that
became successful not working hard I
don't know a single person that became
successful not working hard now let me
explain this if this guy works hard and
this guy works hard they both worked
very very hard but this guy learns how
to work smart
it's a compounding effect however this
guy works hard but this guy works very
smart but he's extremely lazy he can't
compete with this guy because he can't
even get to the level of this guy to be
picked up the minimum requirements the
entry is hard work
it's just what it is it's just not going
to happen for you to get there you know
right now the debates going on the MBA
was supposed to be the what he call it
the MVP right they're talking who who
the names harden Westbrook Kawhi Leonard
LeBron James and I think that's really
the floor I don't think there's anybody
else in the in the four named Curry's
number five six he's not because he's
been back-to-back so they're not going
to give it to you know curry is not
going to be MVP that's a given right
okay you know what you know what's the
one percentage no one knows here's
what's the craziest percentage quite
Leonard shoots 89% free throw did you
know that do you know how many people
know that's that very few you know what
LeBron James are shooting this year 68
percent 68 percent is the lowest
free-throw he's shot in his career now
look the staff he's putting up as
beastmode he could win MVP and it's
arguably arguably solid but you know
there's certain things that
behind-closed-doors free throws as hard
work you can outsmart free throws it's
hard work in practice
free throws a LeBrons body you LeBrons
body requires a lot of diligence and
diet and the way they eat these guys all
have a physical but that that's a lot of
hard work so you can't outsmart hard
work period you gotta learn hard work
smart people have a hard time with that
because they think they have secrets
that they can do who do stuff and get
everybody else to do stuff and they get
credit until eventually the numbers show
up and people realize you just don't
really work that hard and you kept it a
secret for ten years now everybody knows
your talent scanner where your Apple
your if you would add it hard work man
you'd be killing everybody right no high
road that makes know what high road is
man so I learned this I learned this you
know sometime when you when you build a
business your people will teach you a
lot the people around you will teach you
a lot because you're not the smartest
person in the room collectively we can
all learn a ton and one of the things I
learned I've made the dumbest mistakes
in business I have a video called
you know what was submitted to twelve
dumbest mistakes I made as an
entrepreneur no wonder it's one of the
top five most popular videos I have on
YouTube because people love finding out
about the dumbest mistakes I've made I
can do 20 of those videos
but there was a part about this where I
started attracting people who were
extremely successful in the past and
these guys uh you know would bring their
ego sometimes and all this other stuff
and then I brought a couple guys that
were hard-working and they were
difficult to work with at times right
and if there was 10 arguments to argue
with them 7 of them produced nothing so
I gave him the victory but these three
that mattered that could hurt them in
the business and kill them I'm not
compromising here but I have to learn
where to take the high road and smart
people have a hard time taking the high
road and you gotta pick and choose out
of the 10 you don't need to win every
argument but there are two or three that
you cannot compromise the other 7 is
their ego less than one do you go part
just give it to them the ego part some
of the comments you know let them get it
but you gotta know sometimes there's
things you cannot comprehend a meeting
I've been in negotiations where the
other person said some stuff how one
very big negotiation about a year ago a
person said something that really really
annoyed me I took the high road we came
out we negotiated we're gonna end up
doing 10 million dollars with that
person this year ten million dollars
we're going to do this year it's not bad
in a year to do ten million dollars in
one year with this one business one one
company that just kind of happened
accidentally but I have to figure out a
way no high road you have take a high
road because I don't need to win every
single argument just the ones that
really matter that part you don't need
to compromise because this could put you
out of business
next zero damping smart people are
afraid of adapting let me explain to you
why fear of change and fear of adapting
you know why so many of us are
frightened of adapting and changing let
me explain to you why because when we
have to change what that means is the
existing us is not good enough and smart
people don't like to be known that
they're not good enough we say one more
time smart people have been told they're
smarter all their lives so you're
telling me all of a sudden I have to
change and I'm not good enough yes
you're not good enough you're not you
and I are not good enough to get to the
next level we want to get to in life
whatever that level may be for you this
to change and adapt for you to be able
to go there because if you don't the
lower level you is pulling you down to
this level this is why you cannot go to
this level this needs to shift smart
people have a hard time with it because
they live off the resume here's Who I am
here's what I've done their resume smart
people okay fear of adapting if you are
willing to adapt and you're willing to
change then you give yourself a fighting
chance to make it in business
so anyways these are just twelve of the
points that we have here we're trying to
say something did I miss one
did I miss something here bottom left
bottom left okay I missed this one
writing them in let me get through that
one as well so not getting your hands
dirty so smartly one of the things
they'll do is what's the word to use
righteous - good okay like I remember we
did some interviews for some some guys
that came to run day with you I would
never start at the bottom I I went to
college and I have a degree from
such-and-such place I need an executive
position here because I got a degree
from such-and-such place I said oh my
gosh I am the wrong employer for you
you guys go somewhere else because we
won't do that here we good awesome thank
you so much for coming out boom out the
door I have no time for that
I was zero time for that I had a girl I
hired one time oh my gosh this person
was a diva okay she was not willing to
do the dirty work but she wanted to make
the million okay all but she don't
understand who I am and what pedigree I
come from a wood University I went to
what I've no problem great now watch
this I have another girl we're all who
went to UCLA who work for me at 22 23
years old she had bags I wish I would
have taken pictures of your morale
she has bags you because at 6 o'clock
when she's done with her job she would
stay till 10 o'clock
doing her homework for school because
she went to Woodbury University to get
her MBA the other day somebody snapped
me back as I was wishing her all happy
birthday and if it is that moral I said
yes I said I went to Woodbury University
with her I remember her till today as
immoral do you remember yeah I remember
this guy that's kind of cool
morale comes in hum
she's got the degree from UCLA Woodbury
MBA 23 24 years old she's willing to
work and gets her hand get her hands
dirty no problem guess what she wants a
piece of the company and has a zero
problem with that because she had no
problem getting my hands dirty
sometimes smart people they don't want
to get their hands dirty because they're
too righteous too good to get their
hands dirty anyways so today's episode
to all the smart people that are
watching this listen adjust adjust
you're not as good as you think you are
believe me kind of relax a little bit
you can do a lot more this will make you
a lot more money you'll become more
famous if you actually realize you're
not as smart as you think you are
so if you've got any questions any
comments any thoughts comment on the
bottom and if you haven't subscribed to
this channel yet one handed catch hey
we're going to do a contest at a quarter
million subs right I think about 230,000
subset of today at 250,000 subs I will
be announcing another contest to invite
people from all over the world to spend
one day one day with me to go through
your business your strategy sessions
together will make that on a video and
put it on YouTube where some of you guys
will be getting a chance to come and fly
here 101 but we got to get to quarter
million subs and then obviously we got
to get two million subs by the end of
the year Paul good cash and by the way
if you haven't subscribe to the channel
please do so and just make sure you join
the notification squad notification
squad you guys are crazy you're on fire
I love how quickly you guys watch the
videos and comment on the bottom so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye bye
[Music]